deux jours avant de retomber en
confinement la ville de toronto ainsi
que la région de peel sa banlieue ouest
avait l'air de tout sauf de zones où les
règles seraient bientôt les plus
strictes de l'ontario en raison d'une
récente explosion des cas de kobe 19
dès l'ouverture des magasins les gens
attendaient en file pour faire le plein
les paniers déborder pendant que
d'autres clients laisser tomber les
distances pour s'assurer une place dans
les grandes surfaces
je viens souvent mais je ne m'attendais
pas à cette immense fils dit cet homme
'l'annonce dr nous inciter à venir
plutôt affirme cette dame au centre
ville de toronto l'achalandage
ressembler au temps des fêtes des années
passées certains centres commerciaux au
même prolonger les heures d'ouverture
pour la fin de semaine afin de répondre
à la demande accrue
bref tout ce que le premier ministre
demandait aux ontariens de ne pas faire
vendredi surprise fox à boeing ba
au salon de coiffure taz les clients se
succèdent les gens aux autres malgré une
capacité réduite
certains en profitent pour prendre soin
d'eux en ce dernier week-end de liberté
comme cette dame qui se considère
chanceuse d'avoir obtenu un rendez vous
mais pour les artisans du salon c'est
encore une fois les petites entreprises
qui paieront la facture
ce coiffeur comparé ces mesures à une
gifle d'autres se préparer au
confinement en organisant un dernier
repas en famille avec les grands parents
qu'ils ne pourront pas revoir de sitôt
peu importe comment les résidents de
toronto et de pire au profit du week-end
ils se réveilleront tout ce lundi dans
la même situation
rassemblement intérieure interdît
commerce non essentiels fermée pour une
période de 28 jours
à moins que la situation sanitaire
s'améliore ici quand les côtés palette
radio canada toronto